this message is brought to you by
Deadpool gentlemen how well do you know
your happy sack I'm sure you rummage
around downstairs more than mommy would
like but it's time you started paying
attention to your favorite pastime
because that bag of beans bouncing
around in your hand could be trying to
kill you what yeah because testicular
cancer is the most common form of cancer
in men aged between 15 and 35 it's time
to fight back hold each of your man
berries or as I like to call them smooth
criminals in turn between your thumb and
fingers give them a gentle roll around
don't get too excited though you're on a
mission here you also need to check the
tubes around the back
that's the spermatic cord and epididymis
but I'm sure you knew that if at any
point you feel unusual lump size shift
or irregularity don't ignore it like a
[ __ ] man up and talk to your doctor the
alternative is not an option check those
bad boys at least once a month after a
bath or shower so the next time you're
shopping for one in the sexy salad
section remember to tweak the tomatoes
before you go cucumber crazy puns
hey youtubers is Charlie Deadpool just
advising all you guys out there to get
checked and it's actually factually
correct testicular cancer is a big
problem it's like the dude version of
women checking themselves for breast
cancer I'm actually kind of digging
these info PSAs and it's actually legit
is actually meant to be a helpful
message I'll be using Deadpool to
advocate playing with yourself that
thing that you do all the time and if
you played some of the Deadpool video
games you can actually make the
character play with his balls using one
of his guns of course if you're gonna do
it you might as well do it the most
dangerous way possible or let other
characters do it for you like Captain
America who was repaying Deadpool in
kind for kicking him in the nuts one of
the most classic comic book attacks
groin attack it's an oldie but a goodie
so no judging here while you guys all
check yourselves while this video is
going on please enjoy this montage of
characters kicking other characters in
the nuts
you
I think my favorite thing about the
kicked in the nuts comic book joke
because it's such an old joke is when
writers and artists try to throw you a
curveball
you know the Deadpool character a little
kid might be reading the comic so the
payoff of getting kicked in the nuts is
the whole joke it's just like haha but
then you have your older readers that
appreciate the curveball where you have
a character like Deathstroke who tells
Black Canary didn't you realize that I'm
wearing a cup
idiot so let me know in the comments
what is your favorite memory of a groin
attack in the comics it can be from DC
or marvel Deadpool just happens to find
himself in more growing attack
situations than other characters for
obvious reasons and while you ponder the
infinite mysteries of dudes balls
just remember legends of tomorrow new
episode tonight I'll post my video after
it airs I'm doing a reverse flash ring
giveaway and if you weren't hypo ready
Stephen Amell just confirmed that we're
gonna see an old version of Oliver Queen
on episode 6 he'll have one arm like he
did in Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns hopefully I'll have similar
views on fascist and we'll also see
connor hawke in that same episode hi
recently announced news I'm gonna be
appearing on an episode 106 of Legends
with the goatee one arm and we're gonna
meet connor hawke the lesson has always
Never Say Never
and there is new Game of Thrones footage
there was a new teaser that posted that
I'm gonna do a video for I was gonna do
a video this morning but Deadpool was
playing with his ball sack so I just
absolutely had to do a video for this so
Game of Thrones will post tomorrow well
I guess wait for that to post you can
click here for all my other Deadpool
videos and you can click here for my
arrow video from last night probably one
of the best Batman jokes ever now Batman
unofficially exists in the arrowverse
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight I feel like I should be punching
someone in the balls my hand into the
camera here boom
you